bonjour à tous
allez bien on se retrouve aujourd'hui
pour la vidéo afin qu cent mille abonnés
cent mille abonnés on a littéralement
explosé toutes les limites que j'avais
imaginé lors de la création de cette
chaîne alors évidemment cent mille
abonnés c'est un nombre qui est d'abord
symbolique moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
la réalité des cent mille personnes
derrière ses abonnements
cent mille personnes qui ont estimé que
le contenu que je proposais sur cette
chaîne était suffisamment intéressant
pour que ça mérite de cliquer de
recevoir les notifications des
prochaines vidéos donc que dire à part
que je vous remercie du fond du coeur
pour votre soutien grandissant pour
votre fidélité
j'en profite puisque j'ai la parole pour
remercier également toutes les personnes
qui soutiennent la chaîne avec les
partages de vidéos avec les commentaires
également les personnes qui me
soutiennent financièrement que ce soit
sur tipi également par le système des
souscriptions directement sur la chaîne
youtube votre soutien est évidemment
très utile d'un point de vue matériel
mais également du point de vue moral du
point de vue de la motivation vous
m'apportez parce que croyez moi que
lorsqu'on reçoit un petit mail pour me
dire qu'on a reçu un don même modeste et
bien c'est quelque chose qui nous
encourage ses quelque chose qui nous
donne envie de continuer donc rien pour
ça merci énormément avoue pousse alors
cent mille abonnés on commence à
s'approcher des chaînes moyenne sur
youtube on n'est pas encore dans les
grosses chaînes qui compte plus d'un
million d'abonnés mais en tout cas les
chaînes moyenne qu'est-ce que ça va
changer concrètement sur la chaîne bien
pour l'instant pas grand chose c'est à
dire que je vais continuer à poursuivre
les formats qui vous plaisent notamment
les audio philosophique qui vous
plaisent toujours de plus en plus même
je continuerai également de faire
parfois des vidéos filmées comme celle
ci est là c'est un petit peu
exceptionnelle puisque c'est une faq
mais je continuerai malgré toi faire des
vidéos filmées et je compte également
lancer un nouveau format dont je vous
parlerai à l'occasion de cette faq
puisque l'une des questions qui m'a été
posée par un internaute parle justement
de ça en attendant j'ai un grand nombre
de questions team attendent donc on va
pas perdre davantage de temps et encore
une fois bien désolé à toutes les
personnes auxquelles je ne répondrai pas
dans cette vidéo mais évidemment vous
aurez d'autres occasions de vous
rattraper donc on y va c'est parti pour
la première question
ça m'intéresserait de savoir comment tu
prépares tu es vidéo même les détails
techniques ennuyeux m'intéresse
alors puisqu'on me le demande je vais
parler des détails ennuyeux de la
préparation de mes vidéos
alors faut savoir que il ya différents
formation la chaîne comme vous le savez
et je ne prépare pas de la même façon
les différents types de vidéos
on va commencer par parler des vidéos
qui vous plaisent de plus en tout cas
dans la majorité c'est à dire les vidéos
audio les audio philosophique qui sont
des vidéos que je ne prépare quasiment
pas quand je dis quasiment pas c'est à
dire que j'ai d'abord l'idée j'élabore
le thème l'auteur dont je vais parler et
puis ensuite sur une feuille de
brouillon sur une feuille a4
je vais noter les idées principales les
idées dont j'ai vraiment envie de parler
que je ne souhaite vraiment pas oublié
dans ma vidéo parce que ça m'est arrivé
au début lorsque je commençais à
réaliser ce type de vidéos de demeurer
écouter ensuite et de me dire masse
là je lui ai parlé quelque chose
d'important et ça crée une sorte de
frustration de gênes comme si finalement
j'avais mal fait mon travail
et ça c'est quelque chose que je déteste
donc j'ai pris l'habitude de noter les
grands axes les lignes directrices ou
les grandes idées que je voulais aborder
dans des vidéos et ensuite j'approuve is
j'improvise c'est à dire que hier je
parle et puis au fur et à mesure de
l'avancée des explications les idées me
viennent les exemples me viennent les
anecdotes mondiale et c'est comme ça que
se construit la vidéo ce que vous ne
voyez pas sur ces vidéos c'est qu'il ya
un travail de montage et notamment un
travail de coupure travail de coupure
parce que ça peut m'arriver des fois de
m'emballer parler pendant 2h 2h30 sur
une vidéo qui va finalement au total
duré 30 40 ou 50 minutes je sais parmi
vous certains voudraient que je garde
c'est moment coupée au montage
mais je vous assure que lorsque je fais
mon montage je sais ce que je fais et
tout est pensé tout est travaillé par
exemple le rythme de mon allocution il
est volontaire les silences que je
laisse que je place dans mes vidéos sont
volontaires ils ont une fonction parfois
j'ai des personnes qui disent en
commentaire tu pourrais parler plus
rapidement ou cette vidéo pourrait durer
moins de temps elle pourrait être plus
courte et là j'ai envie de leur répondre
est ce que ça te viendrait à l'esprit
d'écouté ta chanson préférée en accéléré
est-ce que tu écouteras chance
préférez en vitesse x 2 ça m'étonnerait
pourquoi parce que le rythme et la
mélodie bien c'est ça finalement
l'essence de la chanson c'est son rythme
et c'est sa mélodie bien moi mes vidéos
mais audio philosophique
elles ont un rythme un rythme dont je
décide et elles ont une mélodie qui sont
mes paroles et c'est cette alliance cet
alliage entre le rythme et la mélodie
bien qui va créer ensuite ce que je
considère comme étant une bonne vidéo
voilà comment j'organise mon travail
pour les audio maintenant pour les
vidéos filmées il y en a certaines que
je script c'est à dire dont le texte est
écrit de a à z sur lesquels ça peut
m'arriver d'improviser et parfois de
garder des phrases qui n'était pas prévu
à l'écriture comme ça peut également
m'arrivait de finalement enlever
certaines phrases que j'avais privé au
scripps et qui al'oreille justement
j'insiste beaucoup sur cette question de
la la musicalité du propos à l'oreille
je finis par me dire que ces phrases
vont surcharge et vont alourdir le
propos et dans ce cas là ça va m'arriver
de les couper au montage
il faut savoir que lorsqu'une vidéo vous
paraît avoir été réalisés facilement
c'est la preuve qu'elle est réussie
parce que c'est une vidéo dont vous ne
voyez pas les défauts c'est donc une
vidéo dont on a réussi à éliminer tous
les défauts et c'est vraiment comme ça
que je conçois moi le travail de
réalisation de mes vidéos
je fais en sorte que l'on se dise que
cette vidéo a été facile à réaliser et
si c'est ce qu'on se dit si on a
l'impression que je les fait d'une trex
ou que je n'ai quasiment pas passer de
temps sur mon montage et bien c'est la
preuve pour moi que la vidéo est réussi
question suivante pourquoi ne pas faire
des podcasts ou mettre les vidéos en
podcast sur les plateformes de streaming
alors excellente question qu'on m'a déjà
souvent posée je t'avouerai que la seule
raison pour laquelle je n'ai pas encore
mis mes audio philosophique sur des
plateformes de podcasts c'est tout
simplement par manque de temps parce que
je suis tout seul à gérer l'entièreté de
l'activité de la chaîne et que même si
ça n'a l'air de rien quand on est de
l'autre côté de l'écran mettre en ligne
des vidéos ou des audio remplir tous les
onglets remplir lancar description la
simple mise en ligne qui prend du temps
aussi un
c'est quelque chose de très chronophage
et on est obligé parfois de sacrifier
des choses au profit de des priorités de
notre priorité c'est que mes audio soit
vu que je puisse en faire d'autres que
j'ai le temps d'en faire d'autres
et donc ça ça m'impose aussi de faire
des choix peut-être que lorsque j'aurai
davantage de temps lorsque j'aurai plus
de latitude dans mon travail sur ma
chaîne youtube
à ce moment là hier je pourrais
diversifier les plateformes est
effectivement mettre en ligne mais audio
sur des plateformes dédiées question
suivante
concrètement qu'est-ce qui vous aident à
combattre la procrastination la passion
la passion s'estima de la combattre la
procrastination
parce que quand on a de la passion on a
de l'énergie et quand on a de l'énergie
on n'a pas envie de remettre au
lendemain ce qu'on pourrait faire le
jour même
moi mon problème n'est pas que je remets
au lendemain ce que je n'ai pas envie de
faire mon problème c'est que je suis
déjà au lendemain alors que je n'ai pas
fini ce que j'étais déjà en train de
faire mon problème c'est que je manque
de temps des idées j'en et de l'énergie
jean né de la volonté
j'en ai mais le temps c'est quelque
chose que j'ai du mal à avoir c'est ce
bien le plus précieux qui est à la fois
notre adversaire notre ennemi comme
disait baudelaire mais aussi notre allié
parce que c'est grâce au temps et bien
qu'on peut qu'on peut s'accomplir et
qu'on peut accomplir ce qui nous
passionne dans la vie maintenant
sans vouloir donner l'air d'avoir un
discours un peu trop simpliste ou un peu
trop réducteur j'ai envie de te dire que
la procrastination c'est toi qui décides
de la subir
ou pas la volonté n'est pas quelque
chose qui est totalement étranger à nous
mêmes la volonté qui nous anime ou qui
nous fait défaut
en réalité on a un pouvoir sur elle par
exemple il ya des personnes qui vont
aller se bourrer la gueule tous les
soirs se coucher à 4 heures du matin se
lever à midi et qui vont nous expliquer
que l manque de volonté quel manque de
motivation qu'elles ne comprennent pas
pourquoi certaines personnes y arriver
qu'elle n'y arrive pas bon parfois le
problème est simplement sous notre nez
et on refuse de le voir quand on a une
mauvaise hygiène de vie quand on a une
mauvaise alimentation
quand on ne fait pas d'activité physique
il est normal que notre volonté soit un
petit peu amoindrie c'est tout à fait
normal
la volonté n'est pas quelque chose qui
dépend d'un coup de baguette magique ou
de la bonne grâce de la fortune la
volonté c'est quelque chose sur quoi on
peut influer à condition de mettre en
place certaines pratiques certains
automatismes certains rituels j'en ai
parlé dans ma vidéo justement sur
l'habitude
et ça ça suppose des efforts au
quotidien ça suppose un certain nombre
de sacrifices
ça suppose par exemple de refuser
d'aller boire des verres avec des amis
parce que on a quelque chose à terminer
et que lorsqu'on aura terminé on aura
une satisfaction on aura une fierté qui
va largement dépasser le plaisir
éphémère qu'on aurait pu avoir
allez boire des verres même si c'est
très important d'aller boire des verres
avec ses amis ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que la procrastination c'est
souvent une altération de la volonté est
que la volonté c'est quelque chose sur
quoi on peut avoir une force d'
influence à condition de mettre en place
certaines pratiques et certains
automatismes question suivante que
conseillerais tu as un jeune qui arrête
ses études
question d'alex alors mon cher alex je
te répondrais spontanément que arrêté
ses études
ce n'est pas un projet on arrête ses
études parce que on fait quelque chose
d'autre à la place donc la question
d'abord que j'ai envie de te poser c'est
est-ce que tu as un plan b est-ce que tu
as un projet qui justifierait d'arrêter
ses études parce qu'on n'arrête pas ses
études pour arrêter ses études il faut
que ça serve quelque chose que ça serve
une autre une autre finalité
donc si tu arrêtes tes études parce que
tu as un projet un projet qui te
passionne et un projet qui soit aussi
réaliste parce qu'il ne sert à rien de
se lancer dans une quête perdu d'avancé
souvent quelque chose qu'on a tendance à
faire de se lancer dans des objectifs
totalement inatteignable pour ensuite
pouvoir justifier le fait de ne pas
avoir réussi
moi je ne suis pas de cette école là je
pense qu'il faut toujours avoir un
objectif qui soit atteignable qui soit
réaliste et si tu as non seulement la
passion la détermination mais aussi les
moyens c'est à dire les moyens matériels
et immatériels pour mener à terme cet
objectif qui le tient là ce moment là tu
peux arrêter tes études en toute
sérénité tu peut les arrêter sans
culpabiliser ou sans te dire que tu va
décevoir tes parents ta famille ton
entourage parce que ça on s'en fout cet
avis c'est toi qui vas la mener
donc si tu as un projet viable et bien
j'ai envie de te dire fons foncé ne te
pose pas de question et seule question
que doit se poser
ce sont les questions qui vont t'aider à
atteindre son objectif ce sont les
questions qui vont nourrir mon projet
est de permettre d'apprendre de
t'améliorer et donc de te rapprocher de
cet objectif que tu te fixes question
suivante est ce que tu as déjà abordé le
thème de l'addiction sinon quand tu en
parles
alors la question de l'addiction je l'
ai abordé dans une vidéo qui est la
vidéo sur la pornographie
chez les jeunes mais c'était un
traitement localisé de la question de
l'addiction c'est à dire c'était la
diction appliquée à un cas particulier
mais je n'ai pas abordé la question de
l'addiction de manière générale c'est
quelque chose que je compte ferme parce
que j'entends beaucoup de choses qui me
paraissent on va dire sinon fosse du
moins très mal formulées sur la question
de l'addiction
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya beaucoup de
deux présupposés au niveau sémantique au
niveau des mots qu'on utilise qui nous
amène dans des impasses intellectuelle
par exemple lorsque j'entends dire
quelqu'un que boire un verre d'alcool
par jour c'est être alcoolique
je trouve qu'on est dans une sorte de
d'homogénéisation de tous qui n'a plus
aucun sens parce qu'à ce moment là tout
est addictif avoir un rapport sexuel par
jour c'est de la diction jouer une
partie de jeu vidéo par jour
c'est de la diction donc tout peut être
qualifiée d' addiction à partir du
moment où c'est quelque chose de
quotidien
or ce critère de la fréquence de la
quotidienneté d'une action pour définir
la diction me semble être un très
mauvais critère parce qu'il ya des
addictions dans ce cas là qui sont très
saines à la salle de sport tous les
jours
allez faire une heure de marche tous les
jours si c'est addictif
où est le problème à ce moment là ça
veut dire que l'addiction est positive
or on entend bien dans le mot addiction
qui ne s'agit pas de quelque chose de
positif qu'il s'agit de quelque chose au
contraire de l'ordre de l'anomalie ou de
la pathologie donc si on commence à
appeler addiction tout un tas de petites
choses qui n'entraîne pas de
dysfonctionnement au niveau de notre
quotidien au niveau de notre vie sociale
au niveau de notre vie professionnelle
mais à ce moment là je trouve que le
terme d' addiction est non seulement
très mal choisi mais même qu'il induit
en erreur
il induit en erreur parce qu'il partie
site de cette logique de l'auto
culpabilisation permanente qui pour moi
est un frein à l'action est un frein à
l'accomplissement parce que ça consiste
à dire que dès qu'on fait un pas de côté
c'est mal dès qu'on fait un pas de côté
il faut rentrer dans le droit chemin
moi cette vision là je ne la partage pas
je n'applique pas je ne la prom' pas
parce que je pense que c'est tout
simplement une vision qui est
profondément contraire à la vie et à
l'essence de la vie et les sens de la
vie ce sont les irrégularités les sens
de la vie c'est le relief les sens de la
vie c'est aussi faire des choses qui ne
rentrent pas très exactement dans la
ligne droite de la norme et à côté de ça
ça ne m'empêche pas d'être extrêmement
non seulement vigilant mais aussi très
critique envers certaines pratiques que
je considère être des pratiques
addictives sans même que l'on s'en rende
compte par exemple le fait de ne pas
pouvoir s'empêcher d'interrompre ses
interlocuteurs pour moins ça relève de
la diction et c'est une addiction qui
est beaucoup plus polluante est toxique
que le fait de boire un verre de vin ou
de boire une bière par jour donc moins
j'évalue une addiction au regard de la
nuisance objective quel produit dans la
vie de l'individu et c'est tout ça dont
j'aimerais parler dans une vidéo que je
ferai peut-être sur le thème de
l'addiction question suivante questions
personnelles tu as quel âge j'ai 34 ans
faut-il être modeste max alors max 6 et
1 seule qualité
oui vaut mieux être modeste mais plus
sérieusement je dirais qu'il faut
distinguer la modestie de l'humilité la
modestie c'est la démonstration
d'humilité c'est ce qui fait qu'on va
dire par exemple je n'ai rien fait
d'extraordinaire je ne mérite pas les
compliments tu me fais et c'est donc
cette cette humilité exacerbée c'est ça
la modestie et je pense que la modestie
trahit parfois une fausse humilité donc
l'humilité c'est tout simplement
d'accepter de ne pas être toujours au
devant de la scène d'accepter de ne pas
être toujours le centre des attentions
et aussi d'accepter certaine forme
d'injustice par exemple le fait d'être
l'auteur de quelque chose dont on
reconnaît la valeur mais de ne pas être
reconnus soi même comme l'auteur de
cette chose c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut savoir accepter parce qu'après tout
c'est pas grave de ne pas recevoir le
titre de ne pas être reconnus comme
étant l'auteur de quelque chose comme
étant celui grâce à qui telle chose a
été possible c'est pas grave finalement
la question qu'on doit se poser c'est
que m'apporterait cette reconnaissance
comme apporterait cette valorisation
symbolique du statut
et en réalité on s'aperçoit que le
statut est souvent beaucoup plus source
d'encombrement que d'autres choses donc
au final l'humilité c'est peut-être le
meilleur moyen de se soulager la
question suivante comment vivre sans la
pression écrasante du regard d'autrui
and as bien las on est dans le
prolongement de la question précédente
je te répondrais que la pression du
regard d'autrui n'était qu' rasante que
dans la mesure où tu la laisses être
écrasante
parce que le regard d'autrui tu peux
décider de ne pas le croiser tu peux
décider de vivre sans le regard d'autrui
déjà qu'est ce que c'est autrui ça
désigne qui autrui est-ce que autrui
c'est ta femme
est-ce que c'est ta mère est ce que
c'est ton enfant est ce que c'est on
boulanger est ce que c'est ton voisin
est ce que c'est celui que tu vas croisé
une seule fois dans ta vie et tu ne
reverras jamais tu peux pas accorder la
même valeur au regard de toutes les
personnes sur la terre il ya forcément
des personnes dont le regard va avoir
une valeur une importance un intérêt
supplémentaire par rapport aux autres
personnes donc déjà j'ai envie de te
dire tu peux te débarrasser de la
pression que représente le regard des
personnes que tu ne connais pas et
surtout qui ne te connaissent pas parce
que vaut un regard posé sur toi par une
personne qui ne te connais pas par
exemple que vaut mon regard sur la
gastronomie italienne alors que je n'ai
aucune compétence en gastronomie
italienne
que vaut mon regard il ne vaut rien il
ne vaut pas plus que ton regard toit par
exemple si tu n'y connais rien comme moi
ou que le regard de notre voisin qui n'y
connait rien non plus donc le regard
d'autrui
il a la valeur que tu lui accorde et si
tu estimes que ce regard n'a pas de
valeur eh bien tu n'as aucune raison de
lui accorder de l'importance
donc comment vivre sans la pression
écrasante du regard d'autrui en le
dessinant question suivante que penses
tu du libre arbitre et je vais est
couplé cette question avec la suivante
le destin le libre arbitre
comment concilier les deux alors le
destin le libre arbitre donc je fais une
vidéo récemment qui s'intitule tu mérite
son succès qui était une vidéo réponse à
monter de la chaîne linguistic à sur la
question du mérite parce que il me
semble qu il y a une tendance que je
trouve très fâcheuses actuellement qui
consiste à dévaloriser tout ce qui
relève de l'initiative personnelle tout
ce qui relève de l'effort tout ce qui
relève de l'action individuelle
au motif que sa participerait uniquement
d'une idéologie élitiste qui serait
aveugle aux déterminismes sociaux qui
nous gouvernent et même si j'ai un bond
dans l'idée qu'il existe un déterminisme
social puisqu'il suffit de regarder les
chiffres
j'estime que ça ne justifie pas de
s'adresser à l'individu en lui disant
quoi que tu fasses et quoi que tu
veuilles tu n'atteindra jamais tes
objectifs
j'irais même jusqu'à dire que je
considère cette attitude comme une faute
morale une faute morale parce qu'on va
plaquer sur un individu dont on ne
connaît rien des lois générales qui par
définition admettent un grand nombre
d'exceptions
est ce que je remarque c'est que
ironiquement nous sommes dans une
société qui accorde énormément
d'importance au cas particulier aux
exceptions le mot d'ordre c'est pas d'
amalgame
on va valoriser les cas particuliers on
va valoriser les exceptions on va dire
que tout le monde est différent et que
une loi ne démontre rien par rapport à
tel ou tel individu et dans le même
temps on va s'appuyer sur la sociologie
qui identifie des lois générales qui
identifie les déterminismes sociaux qui
s'applique à l'ensemble de la
collectivité pour dire et un individu
est pour lui faire croire qu'il n'a
aucune chance d'atteindre ses objectifs
pour lui faire croire que la réussite ne
dépend pas de lui la femme se trouve ça
scandaleux je trouve ça honteux et c'est
mon devoir de le dire dans une vidéo et
peu importe que des personnes ne soient
pas d'accord et m'oppose des études
sociologiques qui tendrait à démontrer
que parce que la science n'a rien à nous
dire sur une destinée individuelle parce
que la science n'a rien à nous dire sur
la trajectoire personnelle d'un être
humain combien de romans combien de
films
combien d'oeuvres en général au
complètement chamboulé le destin d'un
individu est ce que vous n'avez jamais
été chamboulée bouleversé transcendés
par une oeuvre qui vous a fait
complètement sortir du schéma
déterministe dans lequel vous étiez
placé est ce qu'il n'ya pas des choses
qui à un moment donné ont perturbé votre
trajectoire de manière si forte de
manière si intense qu'à partir de light
vous devient tout simplement impossible
d'accepter les lois de la fatalité
sociologique
donc si certains ont envie d'endosser
cette logique totalement contradictoire
puisqu'elle consiste à la fois à rejeter
les amalgames et en même temps
refuser les cas particuliers si certains
ont envie de se placer dans cette
logique là grand bien leur en fasse mais
moi il est hors de question que je
promeuvent sur ma chaîne un discours
réducteur un discours simplificateur et
surtout un discours démobilisateur parce
que je sais que les personnes qui
m'écoutent sur youtube sont des
personnes qui ont peut-être parfois
besoin ou envie d'entendre des choses
qui vont les mobiliser qui vont les
motivés qui vont peut-être aussi même
les élever dans une certaine mesure en
tout cas du point de vue de leur volonté
parce que ça pour moi savent
l'importance à a de la valeur il est
hors de question que je recule ne serait
ce que d'un seul centimètre sur ce plan
là et j'ajouterais pour terminer sur
cette question que le destin et le libre
arbitre ne sont pas du tout des notions
incompatibles il ya une histoire drôle
que je raconte souvent pour donner mon
avis sur la question du libre arbitre et
et du destin c'est l'histoire de ce
rescapé qui est sur un bateau qui fait
naufrage et un canot de sauvetage
s'approche de lui pour le sauver et la
personne répond non non laissez moi
laissez moi dieu me sauvera le canot
fait demi tour arrive un deuxième canot
de sauvetage et la personne toujours
pareil laissez moi laissez moi dieu me
sauvera le canot fait demi-tour
troisième canot de sauvetage qui arrive
laissez moi dieu me sauvera qu'est ce
qui se passe mais le type cool dans
l'eau il meurt il arrive au paradis et
il va voir le tout puissant et lui dit
mais enfin seigneur je ne comprends pas
pourquoi n'as tu pas sauvé et dieu lui
répond tu plaisantes
je t'ai envoyé trois canots de sauvetage
et tuent les envoyer balader c'est
exactement ça la métaphore du libre
arbitre et du destin si vous ne
saisissez pas les opportunités que le
destin ou temps et à ce moment là vous
subissez votre destin le libre arbitre
c'est être acteur de son destin
ça ne veut pas dire qu'on va changer ce
qui était prévu pour nous mais ça veut
dire en tout cas qu'on va y participer
au sens étymologique
on va y prendre part question suivante
que penses tu de la vision nietzschéenne
de julien rochedy alors j'ai vu la vidéo
de julien rochedy sur nietzsche une très
belle vidéo très très travaillé ça se
voit qu'il a beaucoup travaillé beaucoup
préparé cette vidéo et ça se voit
également que c'est un fin l'acteur de
nietzsche alors là dessus je veux pas du
tout avoir une réponse de
professeur ou de des bunkers parce que
c'est pas du tout ma façon de faire je
ne vais pas m'amuser à identifier les
points d'accord ou de désaccord que je
pourrais avoir avec julien rochedy sur
nietzsche le fait est que c'était un
excellent travail et le fait est
également que nous avons tous une
approche personnelle des auteurs des
philosophes qui nous ont influencés et
c'est tout à fait normal parce qu'il me
semble totalement vains totalement
impossible de prétendre connaître un
auteur de manière exhaustive et encore
moins de manière objective
on peut avoir une connaissance très
fourni très détaillée d'un auteur ou de
son oeuvre
mais la proche qu'on a par définition
c'est la nôtre et halit chien comme
julien rochedy sait pertinemment que nos
idées sont aussi le prolongement de
notre condition physique de notre corps
donc je pense qu'il ne serait pas
satisfait si je disais qu'il avait une
vision totale et objectifs de nietzsche
parce que ça n'a pas de sens tout
simplement de manière générale lorsque
je parle d'un philosophe sur ma chaîne
youtube
je le fais toujours à partir de mon
point de vue je le fais toujours à
partir de ma propre approche personnelle
parce que nous sommes tous condamnés à
ça et la prétention à l'objectivité la
prétention à la neutralité scientifique
lorsqu'on parle de philosophie me paraît
totalement absurde et un sens et ça n'a
strictement aucun sens et je veux bien
que lorsqu'on écoute un cours de
physique ou un cours d'astronomie
on se passent volontiers des
observations ou des remarques
personnelles du professeur parce que ça
n'a rien à faire là on est là pour
recevoir à savoir une connaissance qui
n'a pas être déformés altérée par les
croyances ou les opinions personnelles
de celui qui nous les transmet mais
lorsqu'il s'agit de philosophie on est
bien obligé de faire avec et moi je
crois d'autant moins en la neutralité
que je crois en l'honnêteté
je n'essaie pas d'être neutre j'essaye
d'être honnête et être honnête ça
consiste tout simplement lorsqu'on parle
d'un auteur lorsqu'on parle d'une
philosophie à se poser sincèrement la
question avec soi même
est-ce que lorsque je dis ça je dis tout
ce que je sais est ce que lorsque je dis
ça je sais que j'ai raison de le dire
est ce que lorsque je dis ça je ne suis
pas en train de déformer la pensée dont
jeu
c'est ça la question qui me guide en
permanence et c'est la seule
et lorsque je dis quelque chose sur un
auteur ou sur sa philosophie est que je
me ré écoute je suis toujours à l'affût
de l'interprétation trop orienté ou
delajoux personnel ou de la déformation
qui fait que je ne pourrais pas assumer
de proposer un contenu que je saurai ne
pas être honnête
voilà ma ligne de conduite voilà ce qui
me guide dans mon rapport à la
philosophie aux auteurs dont je parle et
la question sur julien rochedy m'a
apporté l'occasion de cet
éclaircissement question suivante
penses tu que l'on a le physique de ses
idées peut-on par exemple se revendiquer
d'une philosophie nietzschéenne tout en
étant soi-même cul de plomb alors voilà
une question très intéressante une
question éminemment o'neal chaîne et en
préambule de ma réponse je ferai d'abord
une petite remarque qui me demande si on
a le physique de ses idées et c'est
souvent l'expression qu'on entend avoir
le physique de ses idées et c'est
marrant qu'on entende jamais le fait de
dire qu'on a les idées de son physique
moi je serais plutôt partisan de cette
approche-là est-ce qu'on a les idées de
son physique
la question ne me paraît pas insensé
contrairement à ce que beaucoup pensent
tout simplement parce que je considère
que l'être humain est une totalité
c'est à dire un corps et un esprit et
qu' on ne peut pas décréter la
séparation entre le corps et l'esprit
tout simplement parce que on préférerait
que ce soit comme ça non c'est pas comme
ça que ça marche
le corps et l'esprit sont deux choses
qui sont en interaction permanente là
dessus j'ai une vision totalement
spinoziste et je ne trouve pas du tout
ni absurde ni scandaleux qu'on se pose
la question de savoir s'il pourrait
effectivement y avoir un lien entre le
physique et nos idées ou en tout cas
notre personnalité notre mentalité
davantage que nos idées ou nous opinion
alors il se trouve que c'est quelque
chose qui a existé dans l'histoire on
appelait ça la physiognomonie mais c'est
un terme qui est tombé en désuétude
parce que ce n'est pas considéré comme
disciplines scientifiques c'est pas
considéré comme quelque chose de sérieux
donc ici je ne me place pas du tout du
tout du tout sur le terrain scientifique
je ne place pas non plus sur le terrain
de la physiognomonie on va simplement se
placer sur le terrain de l'expérience
quotidienne l'expérience de tout un
chacun expérience qui parfois nous rend
capables d'anticiper l'état d'esprit la
manière de penser la mentalité d'une
personne par rapport à son physique il
est vrai qu'il y a des physiques qui
vont plutôt inspiré la brutalité
intellectuelle tandis que certains
physique vont plutôt inspiré la douceur
intellectuelle ou la finesse
intellectuelle
c'est quelque chose qui a on va dire une
certaine réalité même si et c'est très
important de le préciser
on peut parfois avoir des surprises
parce qu'on peut parfois tomber sur des
personnes qui vont avoir un physique
très imposant une carrure très
impressionnante et on va en déduire de
ce simple fait que leur pensée est
également une pensée de la force alors
que parfois pas du tout il ya des
personnes qui vont être au contraire
dans la finesse dans la subtilité
ce qui veut bien dire qu'on peut pas
juger des idées d'une personne sur la
simple base de son physique
en revanche si on accepte l'idée que
l'être humain est une totalité qui vit
dans un milieu que ce milieu va avoir
une influence sur ses caractéristiques
donc y compris ses caractéristiques
physiques
il n'est pas du tout est absurde de
penser que ce milieu aura également une
influence sur ses caractéristiques
intellectuelle psychique moral et que de
ce point de vue là il est possible
d'établir un lien entre le physique et
les idées alors il se trouve pour parler
de mon cas personnel que lorsque je dis
aux gens que je ne connais pas que je
fais là philosophique c'est mon métier
ces personnes là souvent me regarde d'un
air un peu dubitatif en dix ans mais est
ce qu'il est pas en train de se moquer
de moi et donc je suis obligé de leur
donner des gages un s'obliger par
exemple de leur faire un petit résumé de
la pensée de platon justement pour leur
prouver que je suis pas en train de leur
raconter des craques
et à ce moment là et bien effectivement
les personnes sont un peu surprise parce
qu'elles se disent tiens il ya un
décalage entre cet individu qui
ressemble plutôt à un professeur de
flamenco ou un prof de boxe car un prof
de philosophie et il est vrai que l'
approche philosophique
je propose sur ma chaîne n'a rien à voir
avec la proche d'un dany caligula ou
d'un monsieur fille ou d'un cyrus nord
ce qui pour le coup sont des personnes
auxquelles je ne ressemble pas du tout
physiquement donc peut-être que la
différence on va retrouver dans la
manière d'aborder la philosophie chez
ces trois vidéastes va correspondre à un
environnement un milieu et donc
également à des caractéristiques
physiques qui ne sont pas les miennes et
ça ça me va très bien parce que j'estime
que la voie que je propose sur ma chaîne
c'est une voie qui ne se veut pas
conventionnel et je ne cherche pas à
ressembler aux autres
il est clair que j'ai une approche
beaucoup plus anarchiste beaucoup plus
sauvage de la philosophie que mes
collègues youtuber qui vont avoir une
approche peut-être plus scolaires ou
plus académique plus conventionnel et je
trouve amusant le fait que cette
différence d'approché se vérifie
également dans la différence physique
donc oui je pratique le sport oui je
porte des chemises ouvertes et des
chaînes en or
et oui c'est compatible avec une
activité philosophique
parce que l'activité philosophique ne
dit rien du contenu que l'on donne à
cette activité philosophique et qu'on
peut accorder énormément d'importance à
la vie philosophique sans pour autant
dénier les valeurs de la vie tout court
et la vie tout court ça passe par le
corps ça passe par la chaire ça passe
par les sens ça passe par le rire ça
passe par la nourriture ça passe par la
boisson ça passe par le travail des
mains ça passe par le contact visuel ça
passe par tous les canaux sensorielle
dont nous sommes pourvus et qui vont
nous donner matière à penser voilà pour
ta réponse mon cher nico question
suivante qu'est ce qui vous a poussé à
mettre en ordre vos lectures et à nous
les soumettre
alors finalement la question c'est
qu'est ce qui m'a poussé à ouvrir une
chaîne youtube sur laquelle je parle de
philosophie bien je dirais tout
simplement que c'est ma passion pour la
philosophie qui m'a poussé à vouloir la
transmettre parce qu'il me semble que
lorsqu'on a une passion on veut sinon la
partager du moins la mettre à
disposition de ce qu'elle peut
intéresser et moi ça a toujours été ma
ma ligne de conduite c'est de dire que
je ne vais pas me
battre pour convaincre d'ailleurs sur
mes vidéos j'essaye très rarement de
convaincre mais par contre j'essaye
systématiquement de proposer de proposer
des pistes de réflexion de proposer des
outils pour commencer le monde de
proposer finalement tout ce que la
pensée humaine a produit dans l'histoire
et dont je ne suis qu'un transmetteur
sans mérite pour le coup je vais
rejoindre monté sur ce point elle
apprécie à savoir que je ne peux pas
m'attribuer le mérite de penser qu'ils
ne sont pas les miennes au sens où je ne
les ai pas élaborer tout seul dans mon
coin avec mon petit cerveau donc la
passion est communicative
la passion se transmet et j'ai estimé de
manière très prétentieuse que ce que
j'avais à dire à propos de ma passion
était susceptible d'intéresser d'autres
personnes que moi question suivante
qu'est-ce que tu choisis quand tu joues
à street fighter
rioux que penses tu du scepticisme
caribous des profondeurs à mon cher
caribou tout dépend de ce que tu
appelles le scepticisme parce qu'il
existe plusieurs formes de scepticisme
il y a le mouvement philosophique de la
grèce antique mais je ne pense pas que
ce soit ce dont tu parles je pense et je
peux me tromper que tu fais référence au
scepticisme contemporain ce qu'on
appelle également la zététique en france
et aux états unis on parle de
scepticisme ce cap six hommes et sur ce
scepticisme là et bien j'ai évidemment
beaucoup de choses à dire
parce que il me semble qu il y a une
démarche très noble très louable que
j'encourage d'ailleurs dans mes vidéos
dans ce scepticisme qui est la nécessité
de remettre en cause ce que l'on pense
être vrai la nécessité de remettre en
question nos présupposés nos postulats
c'est à dire les fondations sur
lesquelles on établit notre pensée j'ai
lu orwell je me suis beaucoup intéressé
à la question de la propagande et je
sais une chose c'est que la propagande
n'a pas besoin d'être intensive
lorsqu'elle est structurellement
efficiente
c'est à dire lorsque les bases sont
suffisantes pour qu'on n'ait pas besoin
ensuite de manipuler l'opinion en
réalité il suffit qu'on manipule les
structures de l'opinion pour que tout ce
qui va s'édifier sur ces structures soit
lui-même manipuler
donc le scepticisme c'est quelque chose
qui me tient énormément à coeur je
considère l'esprit critique comme n'arme
d'armes d'autodéfense et je le prendrais
jusqu'à mon dernier souffle
maintenant il y a le scepticisme il y à
la manière dont on pratique le
scepticisme est là on est dans quelque
chose de très différent parce que il y
as sur youtube une communauté sceptiques
qui se fait fort de vouloir appliquer le
scepticisme à tout un tas de domaines
ça peut aller de l'étude des phénomènes
ovni en passant par le spiritisme
également l'homéopathie les vaccins et
de temps à autre ce ces représentants de
la communauté sceptiques s'essayent à
des sujets politiques ou à des sujets
moreau ou à des sujets ayant trait à
l'idéologie mais aussi aux sciences
humaines et sociales qui sont des
domaines scientifiques dans lesquels on
le sait l'idéologie est toujours
présente puisque c'est un des
présupposés d'ailleurs des sciences
humaines et notamment de la sociologie
de dire que tous les individus sont
partie prenante de représentations
collectives de représentations sociales
sociétales comme on dirait aujourd'hui
dont vont dépendre nos manières de
penser le monde et de poser les
questions
donc là on entre dans ce que j'appelle
l'épistémologie sérieuse c'est à dire
l'épistémologie capable de se poser la
question de son propre point de vue et
en réalité l'épistémologie c'est à dire
la manière dont on va définir les règles
avec lesquelles on produit de la
connaissance
cette épistémologie elle est toujours
tributaire d'un environnement
socioculturel elle est toujours un
briquet dans des considérations
idéologiques dans des opinions et dans
des croyances et l'idée qu'on serait
capable de tenir cette idéologie à
distance de nous mêmes lorsqu'on pense
le monde me paraît être non seulement
illusoire mais aussi très dangereuse
alors ça c'est quelque chose qu'on sait
depuis très longtemps en philosophie en
épistémologie cette incapacité que nous
avons en tant qu'êtres humains sociaux
en tant qu'être civilisationnel de nous
extraire de nos représentations
collectives de nous extraire de ce
contexte de cet environnement
socioculturel qui va influer jusque-là
manière même de poser des problèmes et
la manière de répondre à ces problèmes
maintenant il ya un autre problème qui
est le problème du militantisme
sceptiques militantisme déguisait qui va
prendre les habits du scepticisme de la
rationalité et de la méthode la
sacro-sainte méthode pour en réalité
défendre des thèses défendre les
positions sociales morales politiques et
ce de manière totalement indépendante de
la rationalité scientifique et on en a
eu des exemples éclatants ces derniers
temps avec tout un tas de deux
polémiques qui ont agité la communauté
sceptique sur justement des dissensions
des désaccords sur les questions morales
sur les questions politiques sur des
questions idéologiques qui montre bien
qu'une méthode qui se veut rationnelle
qui se veut scientifique ne conduit pas
au même résultat ne conduit pas aux
mêmes conclusions ne conduit pas aux
mêmes opinions et que donc cette méthode
elle va permettre de justifier ce que
l'on aura décidé par avance de justifier
et moi ce que je peux vous dire parce
que j'en ai fait l'expérience
c'est qu'au nom de la rationalité au nom
du scepticisme au nom de la méthode on
peut justifier la censure on peut
justifier la ségrégation on peut
justifier le fait que le sexe n'existe
pas que la nature n'existe pas que tout
n'est que construction sociale que tout
n'est qu'arbitraire sans même se rendre
compte que ce qu'on défend à ce moment
là peut également être qualifiés de
construction sociale et donc être
rejetée comme relevant du pur arbitraire
ce que je veux dire c'est que lorsqu'on
est par exemple biologiste et qu'on en
vient à déclarer qu on ne sait pas ce
qu'est un petit garçon ou ce qu'est une
petite fille
autrement dit qu'on ne sait pas ce
qu'est la différence sexuelle
à ce moment là il ya un petit problème
il ya un petit problème parce que la
division sexuelle c'est un petit peu la
base de la biologie 1 je crois qu'on
apprend ça en en cinquième les
chromosomes xx xx x y et le fait qu'on
utilise prétendument la pensée critique
pour remettre en cause des réalités
biologiques
à moins d'avoir des motivations
idéologiques derrière je vois pas
vraiment le sens que ça peut avoir de la
même façon quand je vois ces mêmes
membres de la communauté sceptiques
s'acharner à dénoncer la religion
la spiritualité dans une société laïque
majoritairement athée et où la religion
n'occupe pour ainsi dire plus aucune
place d'autorité et de pouvoir
en tout cas en france je me dis qu'il ya
peut-être un petit problème de
détournement idéologique de cette
méthode sceptiques vers des fins qui
n'ont rien elle même de rationnel ou de
scientifiques je me dis qu'on est
peut-être dans une forme de militantisme
déguisé dans une forme de propagande qui
ne dit pas son nom ça je ne peux pas le
voir d'un bon oeil donc j'ai tendance
personnellement à prendre mes distances
vis-à-vis de cette communauté ses tics
et à me montrer pour le coup critique
vis-à-vis de cette version de la pensée
critique question suivante comment
rester stoïque face à l'actualité du
monde qui s'effondre alors alexandre ahr
j'ai envie de te répondre
comme dans quels autres conditions y
aurait-il un sens à rester stoïque
si ce n'est dans un monde qui s'effondre
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que le
stoïcisme par définition il a vocation à
nous aider à supporter une réalité qui
nous dérange qui nous déplaît et sur
laquelle nous n'avons pas de prise
donc si tu observes le monde qui
s'effondre autour de toi et que tu n'as
pas les moyens d'inverser la tendance
bien c'est effectivement à ce moment là
que le stoïcisme va avoir un sens que le
stoïcisme va avoir une fonction un
intérêt et c'est justement là que tu vas
pouvoir le mettre en pratique et lui
donner un sens donc resté stoïque
ça peut passer par exemple par être
conscient de la réalité
cette réalité qui s'effondre dont tu
parles mais ne pas être focalisé sur
focaliser sur l'effondrement de cette
réalité parce que je veux dire c'est que
il existe aussi on va pas se mentir il
existe aussi un certain masochisme
intellectuel chez certaines personnes
qui est de focaliser absolument est
intégralement toute leur attention sur
ce qui ne va pas et j'estime que
lorsqu'on a fait le constat de la
catastrophe
il n'y a pas de raison de prolonger le
constat dans l'ain fille
it et des micro détails qui vont te
confirmer la catastrophe que tu as déjà
constaté situe à ce que je ne souhaite
pas un accident de vélo tu vas être
transporté à l'hôpital
on va te soigner est ce que tu vas
passer tout le trajet dans l'ambulance à
faire la description détaillée de thé
play et de taiso qui sont cassés je ne
pense pas je pense plutôt que tu va
serrer les dents en attendant d'être
prises en charge par un médecin
en attendant de recevoir des calmants et
d'être d'être soigné ce que je veux dire
c'est que une fois que le constat de la
blessure a été fait il n'y a pas
vraiment de sens a prolongé ce constat
il a plutôt un sens à vouloir modifier
ce constat c'est à dire concrètement à
te soigner donc s'il ya des choses sur
lesquelles tu as un pouvoir d'influencé
et à ce moment là ne te pose pas de
question et j'allais même te dire cesse
de réfléchir parce que tu n'as plus
besoin de penser lorsqu'il s'agit d'agir
al'inverse si tu n'as pas de moyens
d'action s'il n'a pas de prise pour
modifier l'ordre des choses bien je ne
peux que tu invites est au recueillement
à la méditation à la contemplation
bref à toutes les activités qui vont te
permettre tout simplement de détacher
ton esprit de cette réalité qui
s'effondre question suivante pensez
qu'on peut être philosophe et
politiciens à la fois
non je pense pas que ce soit possible
d'être politicien et philosophe à la
fois je pense qu'il est possible de
faire de la politique avec une démarche
philosophique avec un esprit
philosophique à la dessus je reste très
platonicien la cité des philosophes roi
à condition qu'on rappelle que chez
platon le philosophe c'est celui qui n'a
pas d'ambitions individuelles c'est
celui qui oeuvre uniquement au bien de
la cité au bien commun
donc c'est quelqu'un qui est animé
seulement par la vertu mais ça me semble
contradictoire dans les termes puisque
le but de l'homme politique c'est
d'accéder au pouvoir
et quels que soient les moyens pour y
accéder donc le politicien s'il veut
être efficace dans son métier dans sa
pratique politique
il doit être un sophiste il doit être un
manipulateur d'opinion il doit être un
rhétoriciens sans scrupule et sans
vertus donc le philosophe et le
politicien ont peu de chance de
travailler de concert maintenant je ne
doute pas que l'on puisse
vouloir s'engager en politique animé par
des ambitions philosophique c'est à dire
animés par l'amour du vrai pour le dire
rapidement mais mon avis personnel c'est
que dans ce cas là on ne fait pas de
vieux zoo question suivante
aimeriez vous faire des vidéos analyse
philosophique de personnages meursault
dans l'étranger de camus phèdre de
racine ou pourquoi pas beaucoup de
dragon ball vous pourriez nous
transmettre un parcours est ce qu'il y à
en tirer en termes de valeur ou de
réflexion les écoute mon cher double r
je vais t'appeler double r je te
remercie énormément pour ta question qui
est en même temps une suggestion et
figure toi quand en préparant cette faq
j'ai sélectionné la question et j'ai
réfléchi et effectivement je pense que
je vais le faire c'est à dire que je
vais lancer un nouveau format d'épisodes
dans lesquels j'analyserai un personnage
on va dire de la culture populaire pour
le dire très rapidement qui pourra être
soit un un personnage de fiction un
personnage de film le personnage
littéraire
pourquoi pas également un personnage
historique et faire une sorte de
portrait philosophique de ce personnage
étant entendu que ce sera plus un
prétexte
amusant pour vous parler de philosophie
que de faire un vrai portrait
philosophique
parce que je pense que ce serait un peu
prétentieux pour ne pas dire un peu
grotesque de prétendre faire un portrait
philosophie que rigoureux universitaire
d'un personnage de fiction c'est pas du
tout mon ambition sur ma chaîne en
revanche je retiens l'idée et on va dire
que dans quelques semaines dans quelques
semaines vous aurez droit à votre
première vidéo portrait philo dont je
sais déjà sur quel personnage elle va
porter mystère et suspense question
suivante salut charles que penses tu du
mépris qu'arbore une large partie des
gens issus d'un milieu socioculturel
élevé pour la culture populaire et plus
généralement pour tout ce qui émane du
populaire alors là j'aurai un début de
réponse
tim est inspiré par ce que disait jean
claude michel à propos de la classe des
intellectuels est ce que disait micha
qui me paraît être frappée du sceau du
bon sens c'est que de la même façon
qu'il existe un complexe d'infériorité
des classes populaires pour ce qu'on va
appeler l'élite les classes élitiste il
existe aussi un complexe d'infériorité 2
cette élite intellectuelle vis-à-vis des
classes populaires qui se situe dans ce
dont on a parlé tout à l'heure à savoir
le rapport corps esprit il y a un
complexe d'infériorité chez les
personnes qui parce qu'elles sont issus
des milieux populaires n'ont peut-être
pas forcément baigner dans
l'environnement qui leur aura permis
ensuite de développer leurs aptitudes
intellectuelles et éventuellement de
pouvoir en faire leur métier mais se
trouve que ces personnes-là issus des
milieux populaires ont par contre
généralement plus d'aptitudes dans les
travaux physiques dans les travaux
manuels dans tout ce qui est lié à
l'activité du corps et il se trouve que
inversement ceux qui ont baigné dans un
environnement socioculturel élitiste où
la culture et la pensée les idées ont
pris une très grande classe parfois pour
ne pas dire souvent ces personnes là ont
totalement délaissé la dimension
physique
la dimension du corps ce qui fait qu'on
se retrouve avec une élite
intellectuelle qui affiche un mépris
pour des classes populaires dont l envi
secrètement les aptitudes physiques
alors même qu'on a des enfants issus des
classes populaires qui pensent que
passer à la télé pour parler d'idées
pour parler de concept
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas fait
pour eux parce que eux ils sont
meilleurs avec leurs mains où ils sont
meilleurs avec un ballon dans les pieds
donc ce que j'ai envie de dire à toutes
les personnes qui sont issus des milieux
socioculturels défavorisés c'est de vous
dire que le complexe d'infériorité que
vous avez peut-être sur le plan
intellectuel par rapport à l'élite bien
dites vous bien que satellite est là
également ce complexe vis-à-vis de vous
par rapport à vos qualités physiques
pour moi cet art de la moquerie cet art
du persiflage dont sont l'objet les
personnes qui ont un physique un peu
atypique dans la classe médiatique il
est parfaitement révélateur de ce
complexe d'infériorité physique que
nourrissent un grand nombre
d'intellectuels qui sont souvent tu as
tu un avis en tant que fan de
philosophie sur le point culture de link
the sun qui parle de philosophie alors
j'ai regardé le point culture de link
the sun sur la philosophie
alors on est sur des registres
totalement différent entre ce que je
propose sur ma chaîne est ce que propose
ligne the sun ce que propose ligne the
sun c'est du divertissement
ce sont des vidéos ludiques très rythmée
que j'apprécie d'ailleurs qui me font
pour la plupart beaucoup rire mais on
est dans le registre qui n'ont rien à
voir l'un avec l'autre
alors moi j'ai tendance à penser que la
philosophie ça nécessite un certain
rythme dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure la
pensée c'est pas quelque chose qui peut
se faire en vitesse accélérée
donc évidemment que l' approche que je
propose va paraître en décalage
si on la met en comparaison avec celles
de ligne au sun mais de manière générale
j'estime que tout ce qui peut ramener
dans le giron de la philosophie est bon
à prendre
donc j'aurais tendance à dire merci
ligne the sun et continuer comme ça
question suivante
es-tu curieux de découvrir l'eau de la
baie pas pour l'instant non ça va merci
qu'est ce qu'un bon mot un bon mot c'est
un mot juste un bon mot
c'est un mot qui lorsque tu l'entends
résonne et tu te fais dire c'est ça et
lorsque tu te dis c'est ça ça veut dire
que c'était le bon mot question suivante
quelle vision as tu du divertissement
dans notre société actuelle
alors j'en parlais à l'instant avec in
the sun le divertissement gens n'est pas
une conception unilatérale
ce que je veux dire c'est que le
divertissement n'est pas que move et le
divertissement n'est pas que négatif
par moments il est nécessaire de se
divertir
de la même façon qu'il est nécessaire
que le corps se repose après un effort
donc je ne suis pas contre le
divertissement
je ne pense pas que le divertissement
soit quelque chose qu'il faille
systématiquement condamné ce qui n'est
pas la même chose que de parler de la
société du divertissement où la logique
du divertissement permanent qui l'a en
fait à un but qui est l'abrutissement un
l'aboutissement des esprits notamment
dans l'industrie du spectacle la
télévision en particulier je pense que
là c'est très clair maintenant je ne
pense pas qu'il faille ou culpabiliser à
chaque fois qu'on a envie de se divertir
ce que je veux dire c'est que regarder
une série débile ou faire une partie de
jeu vidéo
après avoir travaillé après être restés
concentrés pendant des heures et
s'accorder un petit moment de repos je
pense pas que ce soit quelque chose sur
quoi ils failli jeter la culpabilité et
la répression et son suivante êtes vous
mariée
alors non machart lisa je ne suis pas
mariée en tout cas pas ce jour
néanmoins je reste ouvert à toute
proposition à partir du moment où la
femme qui partagera ma vie partagera
aussi ma passion et pas seulement ma
passion pour la philosophie ma passion
en général et tout ce qui va avec
ce qui n'est pas une mince affaire chose
à savoir je déteste porter des
pantoufles question suivante est il vrai
que la philosophie est morte aujourd'hui
non la philosophie ne meurt jamais et
socrate est mort pour que la philosophie
vive la philosophie ne meurt jamais
puisque tant qu'il y à de l'humain tant
qu'il y a de l'esprit
il y a de la philosophie et moi même
quand je ne serai plus là bien je sais
que toutes les petites graines que
jaurès mais au travers de mes vidéos
auront fait fleurir d'autres apprentis
philosophes d'autres aspirants
philosophe et j'espère bien que ces
aspirants philosophe continueront de
faire vivre la philosophie
au delà de la vie et c'était la dernière
question on a donc terminé cette faq
cent mille abonnés j'espère qu'elle vous
aura plu j'espère qu'elle vous aura
intéressé on se retrouvera prochainement
donc pour le retour des épisodes
classiques les audio philosophique ainsi
que pour le lancement prochain du
nouveau format sur les portraits philo
j'en profite pour vous renouveler mes
remerciements pour votre soutien pour
votre fidélité continuer à partager les
vidéos qui vous plaisent c'est comme ça
que vous m'aiderez à développer la
chaîne à la faire grandir encore
davantage encore une fois un grand merci
à toutes les personnes qui me
soutiennent financièrement sur tipis et
par le système des souscriptions
rejoignez-moi sur les réseaux sociaux
facebook
instagram twitter tous les liens sont
dans la description on se retrouve
prochainement pour un nouvel épisode
et d'ici là comme d'habitude
soyez sages
[Musique]